great workshop for me it's been really
very enlightening and I really learned a
lot these last couple of days because my
background is in survey statistics and
so I wouldn't really consider myself as
being an expert in differential privacy
I maybe read the six papers that John
mentioned appeared in the statistical
journals but definitely not even far
less than one percent of the 40,000 that
appears in the computer science journals
and so I have a little bit of a
background on differential privacy but
but yeah not I mean I know a handful of
DP algorithms but I'm definitely not the
one to to propose new algorithms my
perspective is more from the end-user of
the data so what would be things that I
would consider useful properties of the
of the noisy data that you get so that
users can get the bad best out of it and
and that's basically what I'm gonna talk
about today and I'm starting this off
with this title of a talk that John Gabe
gave last year because I don't really
know it the exact date when this was
announced but I thought this has been
really a game-changer in in in many ways
from our perspective so I work on
statistical disclosure control sites for
many years because we've been thinking
quite differently about you know what it
means to protect the data thinking about
you know what are sensitive variables
etc so it was really a different
perspective so for us it's a big change
but I also think it's a big change for
the differential privacy community
because I think you have to think
differently about what the final usage
of the data will be if you think about
apply
differential privacy at Statistical
agencies and and the users are just so
different and they have different
expectations they have different
analysis goals in mind and so I think
this is really something that needs more
attention in my view and so what I what
I what I think is that so far the focus
often has been about drawing conclusions
regarding only the units in the database
so it was not so much about trying to
think about what it means in terms of
getting inference regarding an
underlying population we had some talks
yesterday that provided a nice exemption
from that and I really like that because
I really think this is something we
should think more about as I said from a
statistical perspective from the
statistical agency's perspective more
specifically and then often I feel when
I read these papers it's really from a
machine learning perspective so thinking
about abuses want to run some kind of
machine learning algorithm in the end
and then trying to evaluate how close
will the results be on the noisy data
compared to the original data and and
with machine learning I think the major
goal is often prediction and I would say
from a statistical agency's perspective
that's not always the main goal and so
often we have as a utility measure some
information about you know what's the
maximum difference between the estimate
I get from my noisy data compared to the
estimate to the true value basically
right and I think this is not always the
ideal measure if we are looking at that
from a statistical perspective
because at least in applied statistics I
think the major goal is often trying to
make inference regarding an underlying
population so you have a clear
population in mine and you only have
some sample data survey data
specifically for which you would try to
then get back to the true value and the
population making inference to that true
value in the population and so there's a
lot of hypothesis testing you know you
want to test whether you have a
significant effect where the the
conclusions you draw based on your
sample actually are also important
regarding the underlying population or
whether you might only have some random
effect seeing that that that only
occurred because of the sampling so you
have sampling uncertainty in your
estimate and then we are really
interested in trying to identify causal
relationships and I think that's the
major difference and compared to trying
to get good predictions is that you
really try to measure what's the effect
of this in this variable on understand
this outcome variable and so what we are
really concerned about is trying to
quantify the uncertainty that we have in
the conclusions that we draw so some
people would say statistics is about
quantifying the uncertainty that's all
that statisticians do and and I agree to
some extent so it's really we want to
know if we have a result we get an
estimate we want to know what's the
uncertainty in that estimate and and so
in that sense valid Rantz estimation is
of central importance we want to make
sure we can quantify the uncertainty in
our estimates okay and this is something
that I I mean what's the way I describe
it here it's a little bit like black and
white that it's not true that nobody
thought about that before
they're obviously papers on that already
but I think there's much more research
necessary in that area and if you think
about official statistics specifically
so statistical agencies there are a
couple more a couple more distinctive
features you need to keep in mind first
of all we typically don't know what the
users want to do with the data in the
end I mean we have some understanding
but the idea is really that that all
these applied researchers they have
their complex models different analysis
that they want to fit and we don't know
in advance what these goals will be then
data as data are often collected using
complex sampling new science and and
what I mean by that is we typically
don't collect data it's not a simple
random sample from the population but
there are different ways to sample your
your units that you want to interview to
try to make your estimates more
efficient or there could be cost reasons
why you use designs like stratified
sampling that we already had in one of
the talks or cluster sampling so this is
important to consider and then what's
also special to two official statistics
I think is that people often think in
the design based world and design based
is a design based inference is a it's
very specific I think to official
statistics so the idea here is you don't
think about the data coming from from a
model so it's not model-based you don't
have it think about the data generating
process but you only think about the
uncertainty in your estimates coming
from the fact that you only have a
sample and not the population so the
randomness really comes from sampling
not from any underlying process with a
random error it's really the uncertainty
comes from sampling
so this is really a different way of
thinking about all this
and what's also maybe a little bit
unique to official statistics is that a
lot of interest goes into astha mating
totals and means which sounds relatively
simple in practice due to these complex
sampling designs it's not always that
simple but a lot of people in terms of
you know you can think of estimating the
unemployment rate things like that these
are important political figures but
basically they are just just means right
and then another aspect to keep in mind
is that the users of the data are not
necessarily well-trained statisticians
or computer scientists or whatever so
they they don't really know how to apply
complex a complex adjustment methods for
example if you want to correct any
biases or anything you have in your
estimates and so what I think the
consequences of this are in terms of a
useful implementation of differential
privacy is first of all the classical
query response system in my view is
extremely difficult in the sense that
since we don't know what the users want
to do with the data it's very hard to
define an appropriate privacy budget and
and decide how to distribute that among
the users because it's very hard to
imagine that you would say you know we
have that survey it was very expensive
and yeah we know the taxpayers basically
paid for that but you know the privacy
budget is used up nobody can have access
to the data anymore so in that sense I
think in this dynamic setting dynamic
setting that we have here it's very hard
to implement that the next thing as I
said it's important to understand the
properties of the estimates that we
finally get from our noisy data
and we need to account for these complex
sampling designs as well so we want to
account for two sources of uncertainty
now we have the sampling uncertainty and
we have the uncertainty from noise
infusion and then finally we still want
to try to keep it simple for the users
because as I said they have a hard time
you know if you need to use complicated
say MCMC methods or anything to get the
correct answers from the data this
probably won't work in practice because
users would not actually apply these
complicated
so what does that mean in terms of
trying to get valid inferences from from
a differential private data set so my
assumptions here are that the goal is
really to generate a difference or
private synthetic data so that users you
know can do whatever they want for the
data afterwards and to keep it simple
I'm only considering the geometric
mechanism okay I know the geometric
mechanism has this disadvantage that you
know you have a lot of noise in the
aggregates and the Census Bureau now has
some more clever ways of dealing with
that problem but I I just want to keep
it simple here to illustrate the main
ideas so the geometric mechanism so we
would turn on all variables treat them
as categorical to a full cross cross
classification of all the variables and
then add this random noise from the two
sided geometric distribution and then
finally turn that noisy table back into
microdata of course the last step from a
conceptual perspective is not really
necessary I mean it there's no
difference whether you have the noisy
table all that no I see microdata
but there are situations users are used
to having this this micro data so I
think and as John mentioned yesterday
for example in the system for of the
Census Bureau their table builders
actually expect that the input is is is
microdata right so they wouldn't even
accept the noisy table so we have to
turn them back into microdata
so if we use the Chi metric
I like the geometric mechanism just
because it's very simple and and and
appealing in various ways first of all
just because we have we have that
integer random noise of course which
ensures the integrality of our final
noisy tables and then also because it's
very easy to to look at the expected
value and the variance of that know its
distribution is it's very simple
which makes it also very easy to
incorporate this extra uncertainty the
noise uncertainty into the final
inferences okay so coming back to the
means and totals that I that I mention
in official statistics what would that
mean if I now analyze my in my noisy
data set and want to account for that
extra uncertainty the first thing of
course is the means and the totals are
still unbiased which is nice because we
don't need to use any bias adjustments
correctly and then if you're interested
in the uncertainty that we have now in
our estimates so assume we're interested
in estimating the uncertainty in a total
that we want to compute it's very
straightforward because I simply need to
look at the number of cells in my noisy
table that I need to aggregate over to
get the total I'm interested in and
since I'm adding noise independently to
each of those cells I can simply say the
variance of my total now is the variance
of my noise distribution times the
number of cells over which I advocated
well that's very simple and very easy to
compute okay and if I'm interested in
the mean it's a little more involved
just because the mean now is a ratio of
two random variables so it's it's not
that straightforward to derive the
variance for that but I can use simple
Taylor series
expansion which is what service
statisticians basically do all the time
when they try to estimate the variance
for means and and if you do that you
basically get to this so again say if
I'm interested in the unemployment rate
so I need to compute the number of
people that are unemployed
you know divided by my sample size so I
have this ratio of two random variables
but I can compute the variance very
easily because I still have only these
variances of the totals which I know
they are very easy to compute and eat my
totals and and I know they are unbiased
so I can simply plug in those estimates
from my noisy table and then I have
again the variance here of my of my
random noise okay so still estimating
the uncertainty in the means is is
relatively straightforward okay just to
show a little example how that will work
in practice I use some data from from my
Institute so I'm working at the
Institute for employment research in
Germany and we have I hope this is still
working yeah okay good which comes from
our federal employment agency so where
we have information on unemployment of
everybody living in Germany on their
history in terms of receiving
unemployment benefits participation in
labor market programs etc so it's a very
rich and very popular data set at my
Institute a lot of people like to use
that and recently very detailed
geographical information was added to
the data set so we have geocodes now on
the square metre grid level for each
individual which of course makes the
data set very easily identifiable I mean
you can identify basically almost
everyone and that data said very easily
just based on that
information and so the question was how
can we deal with that problem and so one
way of thinking about dealing with the
problem was in terms of you know could
we maybe turn that and for this
illustration here I keep it very simple
so I assumed we would only release four
variables so we have sex foreign status
employment employment status and the zip
code and now my user of the data is the
mayor of the city of third which happens
to be my hometown and he's interested in
just computing four quantities the total
number of unemployed the total number of
unemployed foreigners the unemployment
rate and the unemployment rate among
phones and the question is then you know
will he still get valid results on that
protected data set and I'm using a
simple repeated simulation design where
I generate 5000 differentially private
data sets using the geometric mechanism
and I'm setting epsilon to one here and
this will be the result so these are the
two estimates for my four different
quantities of interest so I have the
first row these are the true values and
these are the average estimated values
across my five thousand replications and
not surprisingly they are unbiased which
is also important useful property but
then here I compute the variance ratio
the variance ratio is just i computed my
estimated variances in each of these
five thousand runs based on the
variances that i showed on the previous
slides and then I divide the the average
of these estimated variances I divide
that by the true variance of this
estimate here across the five thousand
simulation runs and of course if it's
close to one I know I asked to mate my
variance correctly and so you can see in
all cases of course it's close to one so
we can actually ask them at the
uncertainty in
our estimated quantities of interest and
then I have the confidence interval
coverage so we typically compute these
95% confidence interval coverages the
95% confidence intervals to get an
estimate or to express the uncertainty
in our estimates right and and the idea
of course of this 95% confidence
interval would be if I generate 5,000
samples and always compute that
confidence interval my true value will
be within that confidence interval 95%
of the times that's the definition of
the confidence interval and so I
basically looked at that matrix so I
checked across these 5,000 simulation
runs how often is the true value
included in that 95% confidence interval
and of course it should be included 95%
of the cases times and this is also what
again so in that sense from a
statistical perspective that's great I
know I have unbiased estimates and I
know how to quantify the uncertainty
okay and the final thing is just the
average length of the confidence
interval which is basically telling me
something about the uncertainty that I
have in my estimate and of course since
I'm only looking at four variables here
there's not too much noise introduced
here so there's not too much uncertainty
from my from the noise infusion at that
at that point so I get pretty good
estimates of the true value anyway but
now in most cases we don't have the full
population right I mean apart from the
census that John is dealing with in most
cases statistical agencies will collect
their data based on surveys right and as
I said before it's hardly ever the case
that simple random sampling is used
we have all these different complex
sampling designs and there's a long
literature on how to account for these
designs in terms of variance estimation
and in terms of getting the right point
estimates also from my sample data but
the important aspect as I mentioned
before is now I have to consider two
sources of uncertainty I have the
sampling uncertainty and I have the
answer to that so I need to consider how
to deal with that and the good thing for
us is that the noise is really only
infused to the sampled cases not to the
population so we first have our original
data which is the survey now and then we
add noise to that which makes it pretty
simple to also account for that in the
analysis because we can basically think
of that as a two-stage process right we
first draw the sample collect the data
then we add noise to that but that's
conditional on the sample so if I look
at my expectation I don't want to go
through all these details but the
important thing is so my feet a hat here
is my my estimate of interest so again
some mean or some total potential for
some subsets of my data set right and I
can still say this expectation of that
that estimate that I get from my noisy
data is still the true value so I'm
still I'm still getting unbiased results
based on my of course still assuming
that we are using the geometric
mechanism here okay and the good thing
regarding the variance is given that I'm
I have this two-stage process I can use
it very simple I can can simply use
variance decomposition to say that the
final variance is just the sum of these
two variances
which again makes it relatively simple
the DPL I'll come to that yeah so now I
just have the the variance from noise
and I have the variance from sampling
okay and of course I don't know the true
variance from from sampling but I can
simply use the asta mat for that
variance from my noisy sample and at
least for the geometric mechanism again
we can show that this would be an
unbiased estimate at least for certain
sampling designs for the true variance
okay
so let's look at an example stratified
simple random sample which as I said is
pretty common with statistical agencies
to improve the efficiency because you
can show that the variance from sampling
will decrease if you use stratified
sampling and also to ensure that you
have sufficient sample sizes and in
certain subdomains you're specifically
interested that you sample enough
records for that cell so it's it's very
simple you simply divide your population
into H mutually exclusive and exhaustive
strata and then you take simple random
samples without replacement within each
and if I define pH PI H to be the
sampling rate within my stratum age I
get my the following final estimates so
yeah just probably Fischer this
stratification of the population is it
based on attributes that could be
potentially sensitive that's a good
question um if they are things get more
complicated so in my situation I is you
they are not so for example in the
example that I show later I would use
the zip code for stratification and I
mean it's hard to you know consider that
to be I mean that information is public
I don't know how you would argue that
this is sensitive information it is not
and I'll yeah maybe we should discuss
that right now because I expected that
question but I think and and that is
something we can argue and discuss but
my argument would be that the sampling
rate itself is at least it's it's a
little tricky to think about it in a
differential private concept because the
sampling rate is fixed before anybody
will be sampled right so in that sense
thinking about you know how would that
pie change there's some bunnies if
someone joins or leaves the database
doesn't make much sense because it
wouldn't change I'm only talking about
the sampling rate not about the you know
if you if you account for non-response
that's something different but the
initial sampling area that hasn't
changed so this is a fixed number so in
that sense you don't need to think about
you know how much would that change if
somebody leaves or not but I agree in
some sense that you could you could
argue you know I'm learn I
might be learning the the original
sample size maybe I think your design is
simple enough so the anxiety was
sampling assumption is probably
justifiable you had those weights
available to you
you could have processed them through
their own estimation system with DP to
get the weights and then then this works
by composition right so sorts of post
adjustments to those weights that are
based on the characteristics yours right
III have a comment on that at the end of
my talk which I agree that makes
everything way more complicated what
what the exogenous what the exogenous
means when you said the sampling weights
are exogenous means that those pies at
this formula came from public
information the final weights zero
probability think that's very unusual
not to adjust them typically for
non-response and that's usually done on
our stratifying on the basis of
characteristics you observe
yeah so I'm really only talking about
the design weights here so this is what
they what the technical term is design
weights these are the ones that only
depend on on the sampling rate and not
on any adjustments that will be done
later on come back to that okay well
anyway my estimates as I said are still
pretty simple because this is the
standard estimate for a total if you
have stratified sampling so you don't
need to adjust anything it's just treat
your noisy data as if it will be the
original data and you can get an
unbiased estimate of the total still and
for the variance estimate as I said we
now have these two components so this is
the variance that I get from my sampling
and this is the variance part that I got
from my noisome condition but I still
can compute that very easily okay so
that's the good thing so again I could
I'm I don't do that in this simulation
study that I'm showing but you know I
say I I wanted to say exactly that so
now I take a 10% sample so I'm still
using an epsilon of one but you know you
could argue that this is comparable to
an epsilon of roughly 0.1 now
that secrecy drops yeah but I mean it's
only a simulation study anyways it's not
like I'm saying this will be the absalom
that I recommend to use illustration so
we use the same five variables but now
we use the city of Munich just because
it's bigger than my hometown and I need
to take these samples so I'm using the
city of Munich and I stratify my data by
the zip code and that take a 10% sample
within each of the zip code stratified
sampling design so this is the way the
original data would be collected okay
and then everything else stays the same
so I use the geometric mechanism to do
the noise infusion and then we basically
still have exactly the same results my
estimates are unbiased my variance
estimate still works my coverage rate is
okay and the nice thing here I think is
that the user could actually learn
what's the relative increase in variance
due to the noise infusion because the
good thing is the user can actually
compute both quantities right formula so
this is the variance from sampling this
is the variance from the noise infusion
so he would already know what's the
price he pays in terms of the the
privacy of the data right and so in this
case we have an increased relative
increase in variance due to noise
infusion of about roughly 10% variance
so
for the uncertainty coming from sampling
it's kind of a setting where central
limit theorem you should apply but
that's not the case for the the noise
coming from privacy because it's not
like a sum of
you know independent indicator random
variables does that affect how you think
about like it's capturing the
uncertainty by the by the variance and
how you translated that into a Content
confidence interval is that something
you worry about lumping them together
that way or you are using a normal
approximation when you do your
confidence interval right yeah a good
point
yeah I'm using the normal approximation
exactly and you can you can argue that
it's it's questionable especially I
think it will become I mean at least in
all my experiments that I did so far I
never run into any problems no it works
but but it might be a problem if we look
at very very small subdomains because I
mean otherwise I'm adding up all this
noise rise to right to get to the totals
and so the sum of all these noises I
mean they're there you get that normal
approximation but otherwise you know if
you would look at specific cells and
that noise he tell you I agree you would
have to you don't why not
because the number of entities that you
after the numerator in the denominator
doesn't go to a constant unless you're
controlling so
somebody had my picture up yesterday of
using unit-by-unit and your case cell my
cell differential privacy on the block
tracked county and state level estimates
nationally and they never improved even
though you are doing exactly the
aggregation that you just described it's
because the differential privacy noise
doesn't cancel our yeah it's not the
idea was not the question was not about
whether it cancels out it was only about
whether the normal approximation is
justified
you don't know what yeah that's right
but the question is for the confidence
into all we needed and the question is
whether that is trust if I'd and I would
argue that as long as you don't look at
too detailed cells in your final table
it should be we can running a bit out of
time yeah that's okay because one thing
I still want to talk about is this
problem in terms of negative cell counts
and the noise was obviously in practice
we don't only have these five variables
typically and so my fully cross across
if I table will be sparse and so I have
all these issues with these negative
cell counts that you all know about and
of course this is especially problematic
if I want to turn my data back into
microdata because I just don't know how
to generate - to foreign unemployed and
so there are a couple of ideas in the
literature the simplest one is to simply
SAP the negative cell counts to zero
which of course is not a very great idea
because you introduce bias because
you're drawing from a truncated
distribution now there have been other
ideas using me for a transformation I
I've never missed a minute I've never
tried to apply that so I don't know how
well that we're going to practice but I
think what's also been done it there
were what's currently done at the census
is to use linear programming right to
find a solution that's still as close as
possible to the noisy table but you have
these non negativity constraints which
makes sense but the problems that I see
with these approaches with any of the
approaches is you lose that guarantee of
unbiased mass your estimates will no
longer be unbiased because of these
adjustments and it's also very difficult
to think about you know how what would
he do now about your variance estimates
it's at least for me so I thought of a
different solution and that's based on
calibration so that's something
we do all the time to adjust for
non-response or if you have on the
coverage so if certain people don't even
show up in the sampling frame that we
use to draw our sample and the idea here
with this calibration is to generate
weights which ensure that the estimated
totals from the database match some
known totals I have from the population
typically census data is used for that
okay and our problem of course is we
cannot use any information from the
original data without spending some
privacy budget you could do that but I
want to do something else because I can
still use the unbiased counts from my
noisy table and I use them for
calibration because for them I know they
are unbiased so my my solution would be
we generate our DP table first we add
noise to that then set those negative
cell counts to zero to be able to turn
it into micro data
I'm turning it into micro data which I
know will be biased but then I generate
these calibration weights to adjust my
estimates back to the totals I have
so how different is generating micro
data and then calibration weights from
like adjusting directly adjusting the
probabilities the problem is I think I
know what you mean but but the idea
would still be I want to release these
this micro data in the end where have
individual records instead of the table
and and there I cannot use these
probabilities let's say instead
adjusting the probabilities in the table
and then sampling from like I'm just
trying to understand how different it is
to add weights to the sample to the
micro data sample from simply like like
you could take those weights and
multiply them through the probabilities
in the that you are using to generate
things and generate for example imagine
you've got a sample with way too you
could like mathematically its equivalent
I think to just duplicating that's into
having like two copies of that one thing
so I'm just trying to understand how I
mean I think it's it's it's relatively
similar but what you would do is then
you would you would have I think because
you cannot I mean you could sample with
these probabilities but then you would
have another round of expectations
require that you know only over the the
sampling design again you need to take
additional expectations I think it would
increase the variance we have to think
about that good but anyway so this is
this calibration approach that I'm
suggesting what are the advantages I
know that my a stomates now will will
again be on bias based on my micro data
and since I'm calibrating to all the
cells in my noisy table I don't even
need to adjust my variance estimates so
I can still use the those variance
estimates that I used before
of course the disadvantages is if I had
negative values in my noisy table I will
still get these negative estimates than
based on my on my microdata so some some
users might not be too happy about that
right but at least I know how to get
unbiased estimates and I know how to do
the variance if I want to avoid these
negative estimates based on my noisy
micro data I could only calibrate to
certain aggregates
in my noisy table but then the price
that I pay for that is that this
unbiased nest property will only hold at
that level of aggregation for which I
use the calibration okay so anything
below that I cannot make this unbiasness
guarantee anyway just illustration very
quickly so I use a few more variables
now from from that same integrated
employment biography's use the same
simulation design I don't have any
sampling anymore I don't use the exact
Geo codes but I a granade them to build
clusters of size 50 which of course is
still pretty detailed on a geographical
level so now I have a sparse table
because my original data only contains
about 40,000 records but my noisy table
consists of more than 160,000 cells so
I'll get a lot of negative estimates in
my table and I'm computing and comparing
the knife approach where I'm simply
setting all negative values to zero to
the calibration approach and with a
naive approach as expected of course
I'll introduce bias I have totally
biased results so that would work better
with the calibration approach I'm back
again so I'm biased as my coverage is
okay my variance estimates are okay so
in that sense I think that could be a
useful approach maybe okay the
conclusions very quickly I think I can
go over that very fast the only thing
that I wanted to mention in addition is
given that everything is so simple I
think this could be something that could
even be integrated say if if the Census
Bureau would provide
these tables they could provide measures
of uncertainty with these tables already
even for the census so that people know
you know we have these noisy estimates
but we know what's the uncertainty that
we have might be a nice feature but of
course there are a lot of open questions
that's I mean I think that's the one of
the key themes of that whole workshop
here that there are still a lot of open
questions so of course the the things
that are happening at the census are
more complex we have that these
hierarchical levels where we're all
sorts of adjustments happen and so it's
it's much more complicated to think
about how would you incorporate that you
know will you still get unbiased results
how do you get the correct variance
estimates and then if you have more if
you have different sampling designs and
as John already mentioned if we try to
account for non-response in calibration
things get much more complicated we now
use information from the data so we
would need to make that different tree
private so things get much more
complicated once we get to that stage
and of course I only talked about totals
and means so what about all a lot of
times
and then of course in the end will the
final loss and accuracy even if it's
unbiased but if we have a lot of friends
okay can you say a little bit more about
liquid when you do this calibration yeah
what what is released to the what's
public so so yeah
before you were saying you wanted to
publish Micro data yeah it's still mine
60,000 each with a weight or no it's not
the 160,000 because that would be the
table right no it's the the microdata
generated so the differential practice
differentially private micro data which
would be about 40,000 records maybe
because the original sample was 40 to 40
mm right and each record would have a
weight attached to it and the user would
use that wait to get unbiased estimate
so this is something as I said which is
common in the survey sampling literature
so assume you want to estimate a total
instead of simply summing all the axes
in your data you use some the the axis x
their weight it's a weight where did the
negative counts appear in that they pair
of negative weights yeah exactly so it
will actually be more than 40-thousand
things just the sum of the weights will
be 40000 because write the sum of the
weights would be equal to the know the
sum of the sum of the weights would be
equal to the population size and the
original population calibration is an
exponential function you know and avoid
a negative way
there are ways to avoid negative but you
cannot avoid the negative rates here
because we are calibrating to negative
table counts so you have to have
negative good point I actually I didn't
include that and then in this slides
because of time what I would do is I
would check my noisy table and and then
if I have that situation where I where I
don't I mean I basically if I if I have
a zero count of course in my adjusted
table I would never have any record that
has these properties of that specific
cell so I'm I'm simply generating some
because I mean again it's
post-processing no problem with that I
just generate just one record and this
will get the negative weight attached so
that it matches the negative cell count
every for every negative so let's